[Musique]
un matin d'hiver sur la route forestière
du maïdo tous les acteurs de la gestion
de la forêt se sont donné rendez vous
pour parler stratégie ici près de cinq
cent mille personnes chaque année passe
dans cette forêt des hauts de l'ouest
lorsqu on est ensemble fruits et on
avance beaucoup plus loin donc
aujourd'hui c'est aussi ça l'intéressé
tu es travailler tout le monde ensemble
pour prier une cohérence dans le travail
est aussi ensuite dans la vision
quelques minutes de voiture et c'est une
ambiance de travail pour les agents de
lohan est dans cette ravine glissante
qui luttent à la main contre 6 espèces
exotiques envahissantes rsa se propage
de ray park dans les ravines et tout
dans ces la nature la nature coopérative
on essaye de suivre mais bon c'est pas
souvent le cas si la forêt réunionnaise
est entretenu c'est bien sûr parce qu'il
ya des gens qui font ces efforts là
c'est vous les ouvriers mais je voudrais
aussi dire que au delà de leur travail
d'entretien de la forêt il y a aussi le
sens de l'intérêt général vers la
formation
et si nous avons deux jeunes du lycée du
lycée agricole
ce grand père pierre saint paul qui sont
ici avec vous en stage donc bravo de les
accueillir
ce qui est en jeu c'est notre label de
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
en effet au quotidien tous ces acteurs
participent à de nombreuses opérations
pour préserver la biodiversité
il manquait juste une gouvernance en
gros il ya eu une organisation en comité
de pilotage en comité technique en
groupes de travail ça représente plus de
1000 heures collective de travail ça
représente des centaines de milliers de
données qui ont été collectés et
rassemblé 1 700 couches d'information
géographique les experts et bien avait
besoin de travailler ensemble et affiné
à la fois ces cartes de végétation mais
aussi les cartes du degré d'invasion ou
est-ce que notre forêt réservés ou est
ce qu'elle va bien ou est ce qu'elle va
moins bien
et ouais ce qu'il nous faut travailler
maintenant tous agissent ensemble sous
le pilotage du département une stratégie
pour le bien commun
10 millions d'euros par an vont ainsi
permettre de traiter près de 800
hectares de forêts et de planter entre
16000 et vingt mille arbres
donc c'est réellement ça en fait que
nous demander les lycéens à l'obligation
de moyens c'est un peu ça il ya une
dynamique extrêmement importante et la
gouvernance et des moyens qu'on y
mettait aujourd'hui n'était pas
suffisant c'est un projet de société la
réunion c'est une petite lili à huit
cent mille habitants je pense qu'elle
huit cent mille habitants rôle à jouer
le territoire réunionnais est connu dans
le monde entier pour sa biodiversité
exceptionnelle ce nouveau plan d'action
collective donne l'espoir d'une
conservation de notre patrimoine naturel
[Musique]